we finally got a trailer for Bill and
Ted 369 focus how's it going ladies I'm
an FBI agent no no it's not the same
movie John hey guys can you follow us on
the Stardust app the whole thing is free
to use and downloaded we post 30-second
reviews and we're doing this a lot more
than ever now follow us first please
yeah hope you reviews the right movie
let's check out this trailer
[Music]
[Music]
one month ago you played in Barstow
California for 40 people most of them
were there for $2 party on
[Music]
[Music]
we spent our whole life trying to write
the song never unite the world why can't
we stealing
[Music]
what's this I saw Alex winter space you
can you can catch Alex whether I think a
lot of you okay let's talk about those
so I'm assuming I mean there was some
you see Samara with his the first thing
was like a baby smart via here and it
looks like she's probably the daughter
of one of them I'd imagine yeah yeah
this looks like a lot of fun this is
like a perfect teaser trailer and for
this there are people who are like
hardcore Bill and Ted fans who were
concerned about this equal I didn't
realize it would raise that level when
this was announced of like there are
people who are actually like oh I don't
want you Dillon's head excellent
adventure a bogus journey you're like
perfect don't ruin this it's only a
minute and a half but it really feels
like it's capturing the spirit it feels
like it's the right tone doing a sequel
this far into the game and a day and age
where we just hinge so much often
nostalgia this looks right there's
something about it it just fits a you
know and I'm not concerned about how
it's gonna turn out I mean this director
he did galaxy son some other movies be
Galaxy Quest which is a very underrated
film which I think has gotten a lot of
love as of late I feel like to get the
director of Galaxy Quest specifically
for people who are like living in the
past and lost in some futuristic sci-fi
adventure bringing him over to this film
it's a perfect combination hey you know
I'm really looking forward to it and
John say some stuff I'm super excited as
well and I mean I think it's cool when
people do like I obviously get worried a
little bit but I do like when people
make sequels this way where they
incorporate the passage of time and
everything and for those characters and
for what there's stories about it seems
like a very Bill and Ted thing to have
them be like yeah guys going oh man we
still haven't lived up to our destiny
yet crap go get on this
so yeah just as a premise I think it's
great Keanu looks like he just shaved in
every scene it's we're like we grew up
on Keanu Reeves oh yeah of course I've
seen a good similar animate
sure I know what he looks like without a
beard I've gotten so used to him so use
with the beard I'm like he looks a
little on now without yeah that's gonna
do
I love the updated you know future scape
you've got friggin Holland tailors like
the leader of the future I love to that
you got the original writers back I
think that as much as excellent
adventure gets more love than bogus
journey I do think both of those movies
are really solid and have their own
merits
I mean bogus journey I thought it was
great like journey I didn't know william
sadler was returning his death so to see
him back in this role gets me very very
excited yeah one of my own favorite
on-screen death performance dude not
even kidding no he's great and I feel
like he's one of the main highlights of
bogus journey as well oh yeah I imagine
this one is gonna be I don't know if the
right word is mature but we'll have a
lot more heart oh you know that's just
the vibe I'm getting and all Alex
winners looks like he's kind of at this
image of no it's winner has been it
looks like a movie it looks like you
slip right back into this role oh yeah
it feels very natural and Keanu Reeves
is voice xx you'd think that would be
the opposite just do the acting yeah it
is kind of reversed I'm excited to see
maybe another trailer with more scenes
that Flo and sister like a line or two
from Bill and Ted because this is really
teaser II the effects look cool glad to
have the phone booth back and the makeup
on them literally took me a second to
register and when they're older versions
yeah tattoos say like excellent and
heinous and it took me a while to
realize but yeah I wonder what this
movie will ultimately play out like I
heard there was some interesting
submission from audiences that they
could do yeah you could like submit
yourself dancing or plan I forget what
it was but doing something like creative
dancing and playing along and and yeah
just like getting crazy and creative and
the more you know insane the better they
even had a part of it that was like this
is gonna cover all spans of history so
you could do like a historically
accurate set up with your costume go for
it you know I bet the finale of this is
gonna be nuts oh yeah
but it's gonna have the whole world
rocking to the song or something like
that and with the effects we can do
today the amount of hype and build-up
that has been for this film really
honing in back in on the theme of you
gotta unite the world with music it also
feels like a movie that with that theme
of music and this might be like the last
thing you expect us to reference in a
Bill and Ted video but watching BTS is
commencement speech reminding me so much
of how music can be such a unifying
experience bill Ted such like a positive
feeling like vibe you get from them and
Keanu Reeves who is like the savior of
Hollywood is the one good one we can
trust the mantas on nothing matters yeah
yeah it feels like a film that we need
right about now yeah yeah I really am
heartened by the fact that they took
their time and in at least the lead-up
to this they kept saying we're waiting
until the script is right and it seems
like they really did that didn't seem
like anybody was really pushing them to
rush this thing yeah I do have faith and
I do think that Bill and Ted could be
the thing that we need a little bit of
right now and I mean those movies - I
mean that while they could be updated a
little bit in their sensibility for the
time there are things that are dated
about them I do think that they have had
an inclusivity that they can easily
build upon for this new movie you know
what's funny I'm remembering this
because yesterday was Dan and Alyssa's
one-year anniversary which is also my
girlfriend's anniversary good so don't
burst but I remember we came back from
the wedding the next day we rushed back
because there was a cyberpunk 2077
trailer but Keanu Reeves in it yeah is
this coming out exactly one year after
that trailer own it feels like it is it
feels the yeah hey man it's Keanu Day
unofficial June 9th is Keano Day I did
hear that they're gonna be using footage
of George Carlin from it might be unused
footage or they might be doing like the
repurposed footage thing kind of like
what they did with Marlon Brando and
Superman Returns you know
it means George Carlin and he was a
vital part in those movies and to not
have him in here he will be missed so I
imagine they'll do it tastefully this
this feels like I'm this is one of those
movies that feels like it's for the fans
it's one of those rare films nowadays
where it doesn't seem concern we're
trying to get a new body this is for the
fan this is the conclusion you hoped for
we're in that age group that gap that's
like if you haven't seen Bill and Ted
we're like what you haven't seen Bill
and Ted but we got to remember that's
been like over a couple touches so since
the late eighties there's a lot of
people who have not seen the Bill and
Ted film so while I know studios would
like to get a new audience I'm hoping
that with the reputation Keanu still has
and with a great trailer more people
will go and check those the first two
out because they're just a blast of a
film yeah there's some how dated in
terms of you know consciousness but
other than that there is a good nature
that has exude it for yeah movies that
I'm sure bill and Ted can educate
themselves and grow out of it all right
guys well what do you think of this
trailer are you excited for this film
leave your thoughts down below subscribe
to the reel rejects please click that
notification about to get notified
whenever I got a new YouTube video up if
you did enjoy this video and you're here
at this point make sure to hit that like
button yeah YouTube things that
YouTube's people say follow us on the
Stardust app Oh additional plugs whoo
hey last but not least David Gandy when
I think about people who are aging who
are really heavily into music want to do
more with their musical talents a little
bit late in their life around the
fifties years sixties years late I don't
just think of Bill and Ted I think of
David David Gandy you could be in this
it could be built ed and Dave did you
excellent adventures he could be Rufus
you're the perfect guy you would be a
very chill roof yeah you would be a very
thoughtful grounded Rufus as well David
I know that right now there's been a lot
of rough things HAP
in your life I hope during this time
you're able to find a way to turn that
all into creativity so as much jokes as
we're making you know how much I love
you you know how much I care about you
you've been an amazing gentleman to us
so please use whatever pain you have and
try to find the silver linings try to
find please hone in on the light rates
and music because hey you're freaking
greater to do 60